[Music]
breaking news this Monday night
murderous accusation why Canada suspects
India is behind the killing of this
Canadian man in BC it is outrageous it
is shocking the push to lower food
prices the federal government's promise
and why one grocery exec says the
problem is complicated a sharp rise in
violent shoplifters the girl turned
around and beat me up why thieves are
becoming more Brazen plus progress and
powering forward women's dreams are
going to come true a hockey league for
women to call their own
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin with allegations of a grave
violation of Canadian sovereignty prime
minister Justin Trudeau says Canada's
security intelligence agencies suspect
the Indian government is behind the
murder of a Canadian man on Canadian
soil Hardeep Singh Niger a prominent
sick leader was shot and killed by two
Mass gunmen outside his sick temple in
Surrey BC in June he was a vocal
advocate for the creation of a separate
state for sick people in India where
they are a religious minority India's
Hindu nationalist prime minister has
denounced that idea and declared Niger a
terrorist today news that India may have
had a hand in his murder was met with
outrage by all political leaders in
Ottawa
over the past number of weeks Canadian
security agencies have been actively
pursuing credible allegations of a
potential link
between agents of the government of
India and the killing of a Canadian
citizen if these allegations are true
they represent an outrageous affront
to Canada to Canada sovereignty to hear
the prime minister of Canada
corroborate a potential link
between a murder of a Canadian citizen
on Canadian soil by a foreign government
is something I could never have imagined
with me is our Ottawa bureau chief
Mercedes Stevenson Mercedes Canada
accusing the Indian government of
executing a Canadian citizen doesn't get
more serious what do we know about the
investigation right now and the
intelligence well Donna it's really an
extraordinary and highly unusual
allegation obviously and we don't know
very much about what actually led the
Canadian government and officials to
determine that they believe they have
what the Prime Minister called credible
intelligence that agents of India's
intelligence agency were behind this uh
this murder this essentially a political
assassination is what they are alleging
we know that there certainly would have
been national security agencies involved
in this but we also know that it's
primarily still a murder investigation
this is somebody who was killed and the
RCMP have been looking into that and
it's during the course of that
investigation in part that we're hearing
this started to evolve but we still
really don't have any details on for
example who exactly ordered this hit or
who was responsible the government
believes for pulling the trigger and of
course there are calls to hold those
individuals responsible all this tells
us a little bit about the icy feeling
that we felt from Justin Trudeau and
Prime Minister Modi when the Prime
Minister was in India recently he says
that he confronted Prime Minister Modi
very directly in no uncertain terms
about this it is highly unusual for
another G7 country and for a democracy
to take this kind of extrajudicial
action and killing on an allies
territory so it's a pretty extraordinary
day in Canadian history Mercedes what is
Canada doing to try to get cooperation
and get answers from the Indian
government
well they're certainly calling on the
Indian government Donna to answer
questions whether or not they'll admit
to the allegations the Prime Minister
has made is an interesting question but
at this point what we do know the
Canadian government done is to have
expelled a top Indian Diplomat it is a
man by the name of Pavan Kumar Rai and
he was the head of the Indian
intelligence service here in Canada it's
known as the research and Analysis Wing
it's like India's CIA so he is out of
the country at this point here's what
Minister Jolie had to say about that we
expect India's full collaboration to
make sure that we get to the bottom of
this
and as of today and as a consequence
we've expelled a top Indian Diplomat
from Canada
this is now a very difficult situation
for the Trudeau government because they
were hoping to shift the relationship
which is soured with China to India of
course the indo-pacific strategy Donna
and all of that and now obviously that
is a very strained relationship too all
right Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa
thanks
well before announcing that news about
India the Prime Minister and his cabinet
were facing a barrage of questions about
the soaring cost of living and the
housing crisis plus the CEOs of Canada's
biggest grocery store chains were given
a last-minute invitation to Ottawa David
Aiken explains what they were there for
what is your message going to be to the
government today they came from Costco
Empire Loblaw Walmart and Metro CEOs of
the country's largest Grocers summoned
to Ottawa look forward to a productive
meeting a meeting with senior members of
the Trudeau cabinet our government
[Music]
prices
stabilize Deputy Prime Minister
Christian Freeland and Industry Minister
Francois Khalid champagne are looking
for ways to lower food prices bottom
line is that they have agreed to support
the government of Canada in our efforts
to stabilize food prices in Canada but
Champaign could not provide specifics
about what that means or how prices
could drop and one of those grocery CEOs
said after the meeting High grocery
prices were a complex problem with no
easy fix it's an industry issue any
conversation has to include all the
manufacturers producers farmers and
Evergreen it's not just about the
retailers the minister understands that
very clearly The Honorable leader of the
opposition meanwhile in the House of
Commons the opposition is impatient for
solutions to high food prices when will
the Prime Minister stop the delay and
the disappointment when will this
government step up and force the CEOs to
finally lower their prices and high
housing prices it took him eight years
to cause this housing hell how long will
it take to fix it
the Prime Minister tried to brush off
the attacks speaker the opposition
leaders bickering won't help get houses
built our plan does the latest inflation
score card comes out Tuesday morning
when statistics Canada releases the
Consumer Price Index for August Bay
Street forecasters believe the number
will come in at about four percent
that's still too high and still driven
by Rising food prices Donna David Aiken
in Ottawa thanks David those Rising
prices are believed to be part of the
reason for an increase in shoplifting
from groceries to retail theft is
becoming more common including incidents
of violence Mike trolley reports
brazen
shockingly aggressive at times and all
caught on camera as inflation Rises
historically so too does theft but
retailers report they've never seen
desperation quite like this
okay wonderful most companies now make
it a policy don't engage it's not worth
it because as the retail Council of
Canada can attest the front lines of
business are getting dangerous nowadays
we hear from retailers daily of
incidents of violence and weapons being
used in the commission of crime if I go
back four years that might have occurred
once a quarter where we heard of a
serious incident
Mass mob theft has become something of
an epidemic in the U.S and the UK Canada
it seems isn't far behind
Chris scholes and her mother Ursula have
run under the bridge fashions in Calgary
since 2003. they say petty theft was
always an issue but they never felt
unsafe until one day when Chris was
tending to the store with her baby and
six girls walked in I didn't know what
was going on and then I gave my daughter
to this young lady and went out called
the cops and the girl turned around and
beat me up police made an arrest and the
girl was eventually given community
service frustrated and scared they moved
the store and when Ursula had a similar
incident at the new location they moved
again this time to a mall with security
just past the airport and just the
approaches we've been taking just aren't
working they're not working Canadian
Police Association president Tom
stamatakis is as frustrated as anyone in
March Vancouver police arrested 217
people as part of a Crackdown on theft
combined they had 4
695 prior convictions proof he says
getting arrested isn't the deterrent it
once was and they're getting more and
more Brazen because there's no there's
no reaction to it there's no there's no
consequence there's no
um you know fear of uh detection or or
any kind of a negative impact on on the
person as an individual desperate times
lead to desperate crimes and right now
it's retailers who are left holding an
empty bag microlight Global News Toronto
tomorrow global national will explore
how much retailers are losing to theft
and what's being done to try to stop it
there were rallies across Canada today
calling for landfill sites to be
searched for the remains of missing
indigenous women
in 17 cities to demand the Manitoba
government reverse its decision not to
search the Prairie green landfill site
as Melissa ridgeen reports the protests
of reignited conversations about
reconciliation and sparked calls for the
search of other landfills
the government owes it to its people to
search the landfills
thank you
a wave of red shirts and dresses made
its way across the country today in
solidarity
in July Manitoba Premier Heather
Stephenson said her conservative
government would not conduct a search
for the remains of at least three
murdered indigenous women saying it
could take up to three years cost up to
200 million dollars and it's too
dangerous
but unions say that's not the case and
came out today joining calls to look for
the remains of Mercedes Myron Morgan
Harris and an unidentified woman Elders
called Buffalo Woman we have members
that do hazardous work across the
country we all know how to be safe when
it comes to looking working with
hazardous material so I don't buy that
what began as a Grassroots movement has
become political in Manitoba in the
midst of an election wob canoe a First
Nations man hopes to be the next Premier
and return the NDP to power after seven
years in opposition
I'm happy to say that um
has announced that there was third
stilento site is elected
Stephenson is on the other side of the
issue with those who believe a landfill
search will cost too much and won't
necessarily yield results from missing
and murdered Advocates no matter what
the cost it's worth trying to return
these women to their families when our
private the Manitoba's serial killer
ends up passing away himself
he will be laid to rest on his terms
those women don't get that today's
action has sparked conversations that
other landfills may also need to be
searched in pursuit of justice for
missing or murdered indigenous women
they hope this movement ends in results
if your granddaughter your daughter was
sitting in a landfill and nobody wanted
to look for her what would you do
you'd be crying and fighting and that's
what we're doing
Melissa ridgeen Global News Winnipeg
the U.S and Iran have freed five
detainees each in a controversial
prisoner swap the American men somehow
for nearly a decade were flown to Qatar
and then on to the U.S they were swapped
for five Iranians held in the U.S it
happened after the Biden Administration
agreed to release six billion dollars in
Iranian oil money Frozen under sanctions
critics are blasting the deal saying
Iran will use the money to fund attacks
against the U.S and its allies the Biden
Administration insists the money will be
held in restricted accounts and only be
used for things like food and Medicine
we're very confident that the the funds
the Iranian funds that have been made
more easily available to Iran as a
result of the actions that we've taken
uh will be used exclusively for
humanitarian purposes and we have the
means and mechanisms to make sure that
that happens
targeting organizations and individuals
respond
in Libya there is growing anger in derna
a week after those two dams burst
flooding huge parts of the city
[Applause]
outside of mosque protesters demanded
accountability for the dams that burst
last week they also called for National
Unity the disaster has been blamed on
Libya's rival governments the country is
fractured after years of conflict and
the infrastructure has been neglected
officials are still trying to assess the
scale of the destruction the U.N
believes more than 11 000 people have
died that number is expected to rise
more than ten thousand people are still
unaccounted for
food safety concerns after Calgary's E
coli outbreak coming up what Advocates
want to see changed across Canada
foreign
Alberta the NDP opposition is calling
for a public inquiry into an E coli
outbreak that's now spread to at least
348 people Health officials believe it's
highly likely the source was a
commercial kitchen used by a number of
City daycares nine children are still in
the hospital three of them are on
dialysis as Heather urich's West
explains the outbreak has exposed gaps
in food safety that need to be reviewed
after two weeks at home Farley Maxwell
is getting set to go back to a daycare
that nearly made him sick he is going
tomorrow
um I'm going to go on wait lists uh like
everyone else with limited options for
child care parents like Maxwell feel
they have no choice but to send their
kids back to the daycares where E coli
spread two weeks later with only a
strong suspicion The Source came from a
shared kitchen Alberta's opposition says
it's time an independent inquiry is
launched while public health does
incredibly important work there must be
a focus on getting answers to the
underlying cause of this crisis and the
failure of the system to prevent it
Alberta's Premier says she agrees more
answers are required in time I have
committed to do a review I I'm not quite
sure what form that will take just yet I
want to make sure that we've gotten
through the worst of the crisis food
handling and safety rules for child care
centers vary across the country but in
almost every jurisdiction there appears
room to improve I think that food is a
very is a is the policy around it is not
strong in Canada and I think that the
food handling is one important piece of
food policy so that's that that's when I
think about it I think they should all
be reviewed in detail do me a trick with
this one the path forward must include
tougher penalties when food safety rules
aren't followed something to really
again put the fear of God into people
running these kinds of operations and
making sure that they stick to those
guidelines because it puts people's
lives at risk and as the outbreak in
Calgary illustrates a single kitchen can
lead to Major fears about people
becoming sick Heather urics West Global
News Calgary
American Auto Workers have walked off
the job ahead anxiety their Canadian
counterparts are about to follow them
five thousand workers at Ford Automotive
plants in Ontario are preparing to walk
off the job their contract expires at
midnight tonight if they do it we'll
send a shock through the vehicle
manufacturing industry already hit hard
by an unprecedented strike in the U.S
Victoria Israeli looks at what it could
all mean for consumers
in the summer of the strike the latest
labor dispute is unfolding on both sides
of the Border we're dealing with a bunch
of billionaires they They Don't Care
About Us American employees at the big
three automakers GM stalantis and Ford
have been on strike since last week
and they could soon be joined by 5 000
Canadian workers the union that
represents them is in talks with Ford
but says both sides are far apart
the NDP insists it's part of a trend
across the country with a cost inflation
going up with companies making huge
profits we deserve our fair share unifor
is negotiating with Ford on a deal that
could become a blueprint for workers at
GM and stellantis the union wants better
pensions and higher wages as the
industry embarks on an electric vehicle
Revolution there in the middle of making
huge Investments and changes to
transition and this strike is coming
right bang in the middle of this
transition that transition includes
multi-billion dollar subsidies from the
federal government well obviously you
see we're watching but as you know you
see that on both sides of the border
that you say an action on one side of an
impact on both sides the strike in the
U.S is already threatening to disrupt
Canadian production so they're very
deeply intertwined almost any vehicle
assembled on one side of the Border or
the other is getting components the
automotive sector has not fully
recovered from the pandemic so there are
concerns that if strikes drag on it will
only add to supply chain issues and make
it even harder to buy a new car in
Canada
Global News Ottawa
next how the new professional women's
hockey league is Shifting the sports
culture
[Music]
with the first overall pick in the
inaugural Professional Women's Hockey
League draft Minnesota selects
Taylor heisey
dreams came true for lots of women today
as the pwhl held its first draft before
the start of its inaugural season in
January there have been other women's
hockey leagues but this one is launching
during a surge of interest in women's
sports Around the World Eric Sorensen
looks at how the new league could set
the bar for hockey's next generation of
players
Jocelyn larocque
the first Canadian and first draft
choice by a Canadian team Toronto in the
new Professional Women's Hockey League
I'm so excited Jocelyn Lorac is 35. it's
taken an entire generation of players
and new investors to launch a women's
Pro Hockey League including women's
rights icon and Tennis Legend Billie
Jean King it's not about a single moment
it's about a movement
finally giving women professional hockey
players the platform they deserve that
hockey deserves that hockey deserves a
message that the culture of professional
hockey is due for change it comes one
day after the NHL saw the embarrassing
resignation of Mike Babcock he was hired
by Columbus even after reports he'd
mistreated players when he coached in
Toronto has the game changed and have
you changed to make it work well I think
it's real important for all of us as
people we got to change every year we
got to grow up but when a podcast
reported he'd asked to see pictures on
his new players phones open up your
photos and I want to see who you are as
a person Babcock was suddenly out now
we're seeing more and more players
speaking up rightfully so and that leads
to to rightful consequences for the
coaches Babcock was hired this summer
when the NHL announced Pride jerseys
would no longer be worn by players in
pre-game warm-ups to support the lgbtq
plus Community upsetting this former
nhler himself a Target of racism in the
NHL you look at all the steps taken
backwards by the NHL with inclusion
nights and and stripping people of that
15 minutes of being able to show that
it's a welcoming and inclusive space so
different was the atmosphere around the
Periwinkle carpet rolled out for the
women's pro league the new pwhl will
have six teams to start three in Canada
three in the U.S and will kick off this
January with an initial 24-game regular
season women's dreams are going to come
true today and we're going to inspire so
many more young girls to play the game
be a part of the game a breakthrough not
only in women's professional sports but
in hockey for new faces to be seen and
voices to be heard Eric Sorensen Global
News Toronto
that is global national for this Monday
I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your Canada
Alberta we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]